good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast
everyone happy thursday hope you're
having an amazing day we're
so close to the end of the week we're so
close we can taste it some of us are
already having an amazing day just
because
i smell betrayal once again yeah i don't
really honestly just like one glaze over
it i don't want to talk about it because
it's so deeply painful and like
and it's honestly embarrassing like can
we just skate past it i don't think it's
a matter of thing i really don't
of course you don't because you're the
winner in the betrayal we're like
literally my own son
at least like did you pay his bills no
like i literally walk him all the time
feed him pay his [ __ ] bills
[ __ ] subscribe to bark box like
still can't sit with me on the show oh
wait am i going is he on the no he's
just getting more comfortable
with his auntie at least he did the
betrayal before the cameras went on and
he
didn't like publicly you brought it up
so you're publicly shaming me
well i mean nobody's perfect maybe this
is an april fool's prank he's playing on
you
oh yeah so i just want to give a
disclaimer to the show like we don't
have april fool's pranks for you i find
them annoying
jackie had like one idea and i didn't
like it i'm like we're just gonna end up
like being offensive like
of course no my prank was like an idea
that i never like actually wanted to do
because it's like way
too crazy and like you guys couldn't
handle it um
no like the world couldn't handle it
like april fools has now become like a
sensitive thing like
no i feel like i feel like april fools i
actually think that like
covet was great for april fools because
it gave like this reset to april fools
that we all needed and i
i really am caught off guard like today
dana got me this morning every year she
tries to get me when she does me or she
has some years she hasn't
she texted me and i woke up and i
happened to wake up a little earlier i
was just like scrolling on my phone
and i opened her text first and she like
said something about one of the vaccines
i don't want to like
misinformation i got this video taken
down but she was like oh my god like
pfizer vaccine like
all these studies just came out like
i'm not going to say because like
literally like the video will be taken
april first is so
sensitive no like vaccine information is
so sensitive right
so and i was like oh my god what i was
like send me the article
and she's like i can't april fools
she's so nerdy like that's what she came
up with she lives
for april fourth i was like who else did
you get i think she got a lot of people
but
people had been on to her for so many
years like you have an alarm set like
dana's texting you it's april fool's
but because of kova like i feel like
people's defenses are really down and
like april fools is
they're having success no the key to
april fools is just like catching
someone who
um doesn't realize it's april 1st yet
you know that's why you have to do it in
the morning she always sends
the morning text like she literally
wakes up early it's like her birthday i
swear
she loves april fool's um and she got me
today she really did so just be on alert
from like your favorite like influencers
and celebrities like pulling pranks on
you like ben did one this morning that i
actually thought was pretty funny
um but all in all i'm like not into
pranks so there are no pranks here today
people rely on the show we're gonna give
you the same old regular show nothing
crazy no pranks we're not pranking
anyone think i'm stopping the plant
theo theo come come tomorrow or
is he or is it a prank oh
everything today i'm gonna be like is it
a prank is it not i can't leave my house
because i'm just gonna be paranoid like
that people are pranking me
yeah and also i'm just gonna like use
this as an excuse to stay off social
media because i'm not in the mood to
have my like emotions toyed with
yeah someone already sent me something
and it's like they got fooled and then
they were sending it to me like look at
this and i'm like
you fool yeah you're a fool fool me once
no and also
i just i'm really hoping that this year
we don't have any moronic celebrities or
influencers
who do like a fake pregnancy
announcement because like we're so
beyond that as a society it's just like
not i
don't know who would like justin bieber
and haley bieber did it like two years
ago oh did they
and they got so much [ __ ] for it good
rightfully so
that's not a funny prank no it's not a
funny prank like for those who are
praying
nor for the prankies like you could have
a baby one day so why would you want to
make a joke about it
yeah no it's just weird so like
hopefully nobody does anything idiotic
like that i'm sure someone will
don't worry yeah no that's the one thing
i can always rely on like people on the
internet for like to do something stupid
and then i just watch but no pranks here
today i
and that's not a prank either we're
fully just doing a regular show
it's hard to tell though sometimes you
just never know what could happen on
april fools
i know i am getting a haircut today so
i'm excited i think i'll maybe get a bob
april fools i think you should get a bob
i know i kind of just want to do
something drastic i say that every time
and then i get the same like
three inch trim with layers and angles
you know like
i honestly think you should get curtain
maintenance like everyone's doing it and
i think some people like
are doing it who shouldn't be doing it
but i think like it would suit
you the curtain bang no i'm like i'm
i'm open to you also like me i'm so out
of touch like i thought this snitch
invented curtain mings but they're
everywhere it's like a trend on tick
tock no i know i know that now so like
i'm just kind of hesitant to take like
permanent beauty solutions and trends
from tik-tok like okay when it comes to
trying a foundation like i'll try a
foundation
but cutting my hair because someone on
tick tock told me to i don't know if
that's a level of like loser i can
get to i don't know i think for some
people though it's like
it's the right move 100 i'm not saying
and i'm saying i think for you like it
could be the right move i just want to
see you do something crazy like i'm
going to think about it
pixie cut change it up stop so just like
spam me with like your favorite hair
inspiration photos so i can like get
some
inspiration yeah we love inspiration
speaking of
nothing that we were just talking about
new episode of the reds heads dropped
this morning of being inspired totally
new episode of the redheads dropped i'm
wearing my redheads merch like in
support of me and my gals also like you
can still get redheads march at
shopmorningtoads.com this is literally
my
favorite sweater ever by the way the
rascal flat song me and my gang is you
and the redheads hundred percent you
should go to shove your heads on we live
to rocky
we live to read we read to live so true
oh my god we should put that on a mug
yeah um so head over to the redheads
book club listen to the episode
read the book snitch's choice just drop
for next month except i just saw a
comment that like
it's not available to purchase anywhere
so like that might be a problem what
yeah someone was like i can't find out
my kindle like if it's not on the kindle
then it
doesn't it's good then it's nowhere so
um stay tuned on that
but yeah it's always a great time to be
a redhead it feels like a particularly
good time
and other than that it's super windy and
rainy here in new york today but
thank god you are here to break that win
no i know like that's what i do best
break wind
and um jackie convinced me to get this
jacket when we were in dallas and i made
a commitment to myself like if i'm gonna
buy a fendi jacket then i'm going to
wear it
oh so many times that like at this point
based on what i paid
for itself i now i think like each time
i wear it it cuts the
the price of the jacket like in half
yeah and i feel like now i'm literally
at like fifty dollars for this jacket
fifty dollars per way huge bargain
yeah such a bargain such a such a great
investment i would say
a great great investment such a cute
jacket by a great investor
thank you yes i'm here to break the win
we have like four good days in new york
we really thought like spring had sprung
and now it's like
30 degrees it's raining and it's cold
yeah but you know what like that's kind
of my mood today i'm just in a
over it i mean thursday like we have so
much to look forward to like i just want
everyone to take a moment to realize
kind of acknowledge this space that
we're
in because it goes by so fast laid out
for us
we actually have things to look forward
to on this thursday like okay yeah
tomorrow's friday so it's like a half a
fake day at work
and also it's good friday so you might
have off right oh yeah not really okay
but you might be able to like celebrate
with your family and you know
honor this spirit of christ right a
hundred percent it's not exciting it
might be a very good
friday good friday millennials
and then we have the weekend and like i
don't know i just feel like we're always
like lamenting on the other side of the
weekend
and if we're going to do that i feel
like we should balance it out and really
talk about how
grateful we are to like be alive on this
thursday and have so much to look
forward to
not only do we have a friday a good
friday to look forward to we have a
saturday and a sunday and i just think i
would be remiss devastated and
heartbroken if i just didn't at least
acknowledge the space that we're
currently living in
and also sunday is easter and so like
an easter party like easter brunch pat
pliny vibes like that's something to
look forward to as well
also thank you for reminding me as long
as we're warning people you know be on
the lookout for
um she has raised the lookout for april
fool's
this is your message like do not make
your instagram caption she has risen
or he has risen on easter because about
yourself learn from my mistakes
people don't think that's funny even
though
i still think it was like a funny clever
caption but i'm never trying to hurt
people you know
yeah especially on a special day for
them so i don't know who needs to hear
that but it's not a good caption and
it's no longer socially acceptable
well april fools do it
[Laughter]
so yeah no thank you for taking that
moment to acknowledge the space that we
are in i'm really looking forward to
this it's so
important to constantly be acknowledging
the space that you're currently in do
you know what i'm saying a hundred
percent is that that's people on
clubhouse talk
especially if you're in a no stop don't
until a clubhouse like that like
that's how people on like podcasts talk
no people on clubhouse it's very like vc
it is but there i like i find at least
the ones that i've joined like they're
actually saying stuff you know the ones
that i joined are like about bravo and
the toast so like they're obviously
that i've joined about like business or
like society and culture like i i find
that they're actually saying stuff not
like it's important to acknowledge the
space that you're in oh actually i
completely disagree i think like that
what the joker just made like is
completely accurate i think that's how
people on podcasts talk
no no no no not this podcast obviously
you should always cultivate your vibe
but
always people on like other podcasts
well you know what at the end of the day
whether or not we agree or disagree i
think we can both agree that it's so
important to constantly be acknowledging
the space that you're currently in
100 and just to play off of that oh yeah
and to piggyback i think it's so
important to acknowledge when you're in
a positive space
i agree because all jokes aside because
as humans we're so inclined to
acknowledge when we're in a negative
space
that in order to achieve balance and
mindfulness we must also
acknowledge when we're in that positive
space i'm so 100 in agreement with you
you are so smart
and i think we should circle back and
kind of follow up on that by
end of day yeah for sure but also
acknowledge like that we're in that
space
right theo if you don't stop eating the
plant a pardon me one moment
okay i'll sing a song about theo eating
the mcplant
tigs and his plant he lives
to plant he plans to live
to zen what are you getting oh treats
for theo
[Music]
sorry guys just had to take care of my
son come up here no
all the way up here you should keep
treats with you there
oh took the treat and ran you know what
he was like maybe going through a growth
spurt or something he's been like hella
disrespectful recently
i don't know i feel like he's been
really respectful towards me i'm happy
for you
um we have a great show by the way
because not only do we have the fast
five stories but real housewives of new
jersey was
flaming well no that's not the right
word like on fire
on fire last night such a good episode
and i thought like after last week's
episode we would kind of take a reprieve
from like all the drums
no but the first five minutes of the
episode last night were like some of the
craziest things it was literally
croutons flying
like a cheese plate it wasn't cheese it
was cheese please like croutons no no
who has that many croutons i know i
thought it was weird i'm like where's
the lettuce
it was cheese cube cheese no but like
everyone was like going
to 100 and then like right back down to
zero so literally melissa like throwing
the plate and then immediately cleaning
it up it's like saying something
and then being like wait i'm sorry like
being like we what did you say like no
one could remember what they said like
were they all so drunk was jack
jack drunk we'll talk about it because
it was such a good episode
and honestly if you've been thinking
about getting into housewives like i
would honestly just like pick up maybe
from like last season of jersey because
there's so much history to jersey and
right now i feel like maybe it's not
that applicable
but it's such a good season i was just
like not expecting that
no from this season of new jersey like
every outing that they have is so
precarious like is someone gonna explode
it's
literally a minefield it's a volatile
group of women and men
yeah no and it's like okay we finally
simmered her volcano theresa and jackie
but like
then bubbling beneath the surface we
have separated and i have to say like
i've always liked jennifer because i
think she's an interesting girl and
she's funny and all that jazz um but
i've officially turned on her because
she crossed the line with margaret
therefore she crossed the line with me
agreed and jennifer aiden might fall
um under the not yet but she gives me
dorinda vibes
in the sense where it's like she could
be as like funny and catch phrasey as
you want
but if you continually say like horrible
unethical things like turkey baster
comment like that to me during this
turkey baster comment is the same as um
jennifer
what no nothing is that one of my
examples i always use it you're going to
make fun of me from now on
yeah she's [ __ ] annoying whatever all
i'm saying it's like the same level of
depravity as jennifer
i'm kidding thank you as jennifer
aiden's most recent comment which was
really disgusting
yeah no i i wouldn't associate the two
to me jennifer aiden
is a little more endearing i because i i
like jennifer at the time
a lot of people like dorinda no but i
don't so to me
she's more endearing but below the belt
yes i agree yeah and it gets really old
really fast but jersey is like one of
those franchises like oc where they just
like constantly go below the belt
yeah and that's where they they live but
they also like
don't talk about like certain things
it's very confusing old-school family
italian you can't talk about family yeah
you can talk about like these three
categories but you can go so [ __ ]
hard on the others that it's like
it doesn't matter what's the difference
um so that will be in our tv recap
segment at the end of the show
and i do believe without further ado
yeah without further ado
april fools without further ado
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
martha stewart and marley spoon
they make great tasting meals possible
every day of the week by delivering a
variety of recipe options ranging from
breakfast to dinner to desserts
meals feature both the classic flavors
you love plus new and exciting flavors
you'll want to discover
they have a brand new menu of 29
deliciously different recipes every week
all the recipes can have just 6 simple
steps and 10 ingredients and they can be
prepared in about 30 minutes ordering is
super easy and it removes the burden of
grocery shopping and
meal planning your orders can be
customized every week to suit your
tastes and special diets and you can
skip or pause deliveries at any time
so we recently tried out marley spoon
like maybe two months ago and i tried
out the chicken and broccoli which was
so
delightful as someone who's kind of like
a chicken and broccoli connoisseur
um i've never made it at home and it was
so fresh and so good and so easy to make
i'm not a chef
like by any means um but i thought the
marley spoon
meals were really easy to plan also so
fancy like i
i'm really enjoying cooking and the
marley spoon um
delivery that i got it was like a salmon
dish with like capers i forgot what it
was called was like a fancy salmon name
and i was like
i just i truly felt like martha stewart
like i'm not just cooking but i'm like
making fancy impressive food yeah and
impressing others
yeah and in an easy way so it's like if
i'm gonna make something at home it
might as well be made by martha stewart
or else
i don't want it i send it back so if
you're tired of the same old same old go
to marleyspoon.com for a variety of chef
design dinners from martha stewart
and the morning toast listeners can save
a hundred dollars over your first four
orders and get free shipping on the
first delivery
but you have to use code toast that's
code toast
at marleyspoon.com marley spelled
m-a-r-l-e-y
code toast imagine eating deliciously
different chef quality meals every day
of the week
martha stewart and marley spoon make it
possible go to marleyspoon.com today and
that's kotos to save 100
over your first four orders love it okay
first story a little more
gen shot news oh my god i'll never get
tired things are coming out about jen
and this
is not news to me but the news is
treating it as news and i want to talk
about it
jen shaw's house the infamous shawski
chalet
is an alleged fraud too real housewives
star jen shaw was arrested on tuesday
for alleged money laundering and
defrauding hundreds
of elderly people in a telemarketing
scam but her alleged victims weren't the
only ones getting faked out so we're
bravo fans
the star became uh notorious for her
flamboyant fashions and her friendship
faux pas
and the shaw ski chalet that she lived
in a 3.9 million dollar salt lake city
rental she grandly passed off as the
shaw chalet
never actually belonged to her the post
has learned yes we we've been knowing
this
we did know this we talked about this on
the show that she was renting her house
but like
it never bubbles up to more but now it's
like
and apparently in the past andy has even
said like he doesn't understand the
concept of renting at all
he said it's just throwing money away
especially a huge home i don't get it
this was not something that was asked of
her on the show at all like
and also it came up brandi redmond
brought it up on another on her podcast
i think and then like
she didn't even say it was jen she said
so one of the salt lake city housewives
was renting from like a friend of mine
and then jen like clap backed at her you
want to come for me with your red hair
and [ __ ] come harder honey
wow gen shop for someone who had so many
skeletons in the closet she really acted
like a maniac
like you would think if you have that
much to hide you would kind of just like
be nice to people and like
put up like like a facade um of course
we knew that this house was rented we've
said it multiple times on the show
um and that's not shocking but i do have
to say like there are very few
housewives in certain franchises i think
in certain cities it's more
acceptable to rent i think in new york a
lot of people rent yeah so it doesn't
like raise as many eyebrows but like
when um dorit and pk were renting that
house that jayla used to live in now
they live in a different house that i
believe that they bought yeah
but they have had some questionable
financial stuff too so like
in certain cities it does kind of
make me question you know yeah like but
you know and then karen huger is renting
her new house in potomac but she's been
very open about their tax problems so
like
that makes sense right and unless
there's a really good reason like i'm
pretty sure
did we not hear that one of the other
salt lake city housewives was renting
too but also because she
doesn't live in salt lake city no
heather
yeah yeah lives in park city proper and
there's like tons of limitations on
whether or not you can film in certain
areas
and heather was not allowed to film in
her actual home
so i believe they rented a home like to
set the scene for her fake home
yeah that's a different story yeah i
believe the home that she has in park
city like she owns
yeah so i agree but to pass off a home
like is completely your own
went especially when it's so big like
and then i
the other um part of the story is that
they found the home that she did own up
until
2020 and it is a very modest small
midsize i would say art deco yeah yeah
and it's not the chalet you could fit
like probably six of those homes in the
chalet if you're just looking for
you know scale reference yeah so
on the one hand this whole situation
like makes me like question other
housewives i'm like okay if there was
like
where there's smoke it's apparently
where there's smoke there's fire like
yeah
are some of my uh other housewives like
is there
a fire a blaze well i mean it's not on
your hand though
i feel like bravo really or in certain
situations like obviously i'm thinking
of
to read and pk their finances have been
questioned they did interviews on the
show where like the producers are
grilling them about their finances and
they're both sitting there like trying
to answer questions
and so i'm like okay bravo was asking is
asking the questions but like i feel
like virgin child like nobody was asking
nobody knew to ask
the questions like i don't know they
knew she was renting her house yeah but
there are a ton of like housewives who
live beyond their means for the show so
i guess yes production could have like
pushed her a little bit and pressed
harder on like how
all of this makes sense on like a you
know assistant college football coaches
salary
but i think they like to keep the you
know the dream alive you know yeah but
they press mary
yeah yeah they do so cruz was more
obviously confusing in my opinion
because
i don't understand how you can like own
churches aren't churches non-profit like
i just had more questions about mary
when i really should have been having
more questions about jen i was just like
damn how did she get so much
but like then there's also i have so
many questions about like leanne lockett
like
she admittedly was the poorest housewife
on that franchise but had nicer designer
clothing
bags jewelry than any of the other women
like it didn't make any sense
yeah yeah that is still one of the great
mysteries of our lifetime
yeah like every single scene she was
showing up she came on the toes twice
each time in different gucci and chanel
looks yeah head to toe
head to toe um wait also you sent me
something this morning about gen shot
which is like
super [ __ ] crazy because now people
are just like questioning all the
telemarketing
phone calls they've ever gotten and
somebody like dug up this like voicemail
they got from a telemarketing scheme
where the woman is calling you know to
press about the
the person's like student loans and like
swear to god the woman is yeah it sounds
similar to jen shaw it's crazy what
account was it that
i sent it um it was just so you guys can
go and listen for yourselves
it was so crazy when you said it to me
like my bravo bravo ducking bravo bro
and they also have like a lot of other
stuff about jen's previous home and so
if you want more information about that
take a listen but at the the moral of
this story is do not pick up the phone
in sterox me
yes you do not ask the phone shop yeah
okay that's
so [ __ ] funny we need to if you work
if you're a video editor like somebody
make that scene in the elevator
and have it be do not answer this phone
it's derek smith to
d to gen shot that is so [ __ ] funny
so funny and if you haven't watched
confessions of a shopaholic yet you
absolutely need to i don't know how you
watch this show
and haven't seen conventions of a
shopaholic when we literally quote it
like almost every single show
oh so sad for the fiscal family for the
whole fish family
but like we say so many things that i
think or like
men like you are the reason i left
finland so much drama it's successful
yes we say
so many quotes that like i don't even
think people know what they're what
people probably associate it like with
the toast as opposed to the
original movie which is fine with me
which is fine with me but definitely
treat yourself the girl in the green
scarf it's such a good movie
it's such a good movie i feel like most
people have seen it but you made a good
point to me like a year ago
that i never realized by that movie like
it didn't flop but it didn't become like
an iconic film that it should have
because it was released like right
during the recession so it's like this
kind of frivolous like amount of time
they can't stop shopping no one was in
the mood right right
during the 2008 housing crisis yeah yeah
so i think
now um well it's also like another
crisis big one
it's like never a good time it's never a
good time for that movie but it's also
always a good time for that movie i
agree check it out if you haven't yet
like content upper
for sure galore i don't know what
platform it's on but it's definitely on
like a netflix or a hulu
you ready for our next story it reminds
me of your windbreaker okay
tiffany haddish re-wears her iconic
alexander mcqueen gown for the eighth
time in people's beautiful issue
oh i love that she is not letting this
joke go like i love this joke i love
that she's not letting it go it's still
a stunning beautiful dress
and now it's back you know the one the
alexander mcqueen
halter gown that she awarded the academy
awards the mtv movie awards and while
hosting snl
is making another show-stopping
appearance this time in people's 2021
beautiful issue
she said this is the longest-running
joke in hollywood it's the gown that
keeps on
giving it's true when asked what her
boyfriend common says about the dress i
forgot that they're dating i know
she told people that he thinks it's
hilarious oh my god he's hilarious
i'm like living for this space tiffany
haddish is in like she like
rose to such astronomical success so
fast
like from that movie girls trip and now
i just feel like she's like living her
best life i feel like she was doing the
most for like two years just like
being like the premier female comedian
and now she can kind of relax like she's
hosting game
shows and she's just like living with
her boyfriend and her alexander mcqueen
dress
and i'm just like i want to be in the
space that tiffany haddish is in like
forever
yeah totally and she's looking stunning
and beautiful
and smart while doing it i love that
she's keeping this joke going like i 100
respect and relate to the fact that like
i think when she bought it she just like
wasn't famous enough to be like gifted
a designer gown but like she was like
pretty famous so she just bought it
herself and it was like eight grand
yeah and so she's like i'm gonna make
the most of it it's literally like the
windbreaker i would call this dress an
investment and
she said she's worn it eight times yeah
this is her eighth time so now it's a
thousand dollars
for per dress and eight dresses for one
thousand dollars each and also it's like
an amazing dress on her like fits like a
glove so sickening
a steal a steal i'm really happy for her
that she's really getting her money's
worth yeah and i'm sure like this year
there wasn't really anywhere to wear it
and i'm sure she was like oh the dress
has to be shelf-free
can't have the joke die but the dress is
back
and i'm i i'm so happy to see the dress
as am i
so also happy that she's in people's
most beautiful issues yeah i guess maybe
my email went to spam when they reached
out
for yeah no i heard that you were busy
and and theo was busy and so
theo's actually really offended he's
kind of you know taking a stand against
people
oh because he wasn't included because he
was supposed to be sexiest man alive the
plan
is shaking behind you okay should i just
give i feel like this is giving me
flashbacks back when theo was a puppy he
wouldn't behave
yeah no i wonder what what's going on
with him
first he betrays and then he's like
going for the mcplant
come here ceo
okay i'm sorry about that you guys it's
okay
what theo yesterday he like made the
show and then today it's like just
trying to take away
today he's breaking the show yeah oh
also speaking of
theo and the show we did a podcast
episode on patreon yesterday
all about the pups theo bruce knowles
answering all your questions like all
about training them and our best moments
worst moments
and it was such a great podcast we also
came up with housewives taglines for
each of them oh my god yes i forgot
about that they were
so funny theo's breath like literally
smells like plant
oh it's kind of good my breath may smell
like plant
but but i love my ass
that's good that's not good
okay also there was like some drama did
you see with snitch and like
i know like a bunch of toasters like
someone was trying to start stuff and
come back
when margo's dms and was like margo
claudia and jackie were talking [ __ ]
about magnolia on the podcast episode
about the pups
which we literally did not know we
didn't and at first i was like oh [ __ ]
we're caught and then i was like wait
what are you talking about i honestly
don't know like what i would have said
because i have so much love in my heart
for null so i wouldn't get on a podcast
and say something to the contrary so
like whoever the snitch is show yourself
and i was like to snitch i was like
wouldn't you want to give us like the
benefit of the doubt that like we
no she said she believes the girl and
here's the thing like she'll never
come to like find out what we said
because she will never listen to her no
it's so upsetting it's like
everybody just listened to it she didn't
even want to hear me out and i said like
you can go listen to it we have nothing
to hide
and she was like i just believe the
person who sent me the message so like
right like after
years of like being her camper right no
means nothing no respect for the bunk no
whatsoever no trust
hate to see it are you ready for our
next story little content news sure
netflix buys knives out sequels for 450
million
dollars they're making a sequel knives
out two n knives out three
netflix is plunking down an astounding
450 million dollars for the rights to
those two movies
the next two follow-ups from the 2019
murder mystery sources tell variety
i just feel like like that's a movie
that like doesn't need a sequel no it's
not a story
it was like a perfect ending yeah like
it was just like a perfect
perfect yeah so i wonder if it's the
films will reunite director ryan johnson
and star daniel craig who teamed up so
memorably on the first one
i wonder if it's going to be like daniel
craig goes and does a whole
other mystery yeah like i i guess no
anna de armas
oh okay that actually sounds like a
better concept for a movie even though i
loved the cast very much
me too and i loved anna de armas in it i
loved anna jarmus and i loved the chris
whose last name i don't know i want to
say let me guess
evans i think so captain america that
was him right yeah
evans yeah he's so handsome he keeps
coming up on my for you page like
sweet things like not him specifically
like his fan accounts being like oh my
god this man
and it's like every time like he's done
an award show and like help someone up
the stairs like who won it's just like
he's so manly oh that's sweet
yeah remember there was that rumor he
was dating vail
yes from vanderpump rules i think about
that all the time i know you do and then
you talk about it all the time every
single time he comes up
it's the craziest thing do you think
they actually did did you guys remember
that random girl
vail i always get her name confused i
sometimes call her aspen i just know
she's like a
a popular ski destination but i want to
say her name is
vail um it was a different chris
who dated her okay whatever i think it
was a pine i can't go back to this place
i can't go back to this place either
whatever okay knives out two and three
coming to netflix for 450 million
dollars i hope you guys liked it that
much
okay like i know that netflix is like a
really big company and they make their
money by like you know charging everyone
11
a month and then now like doubling down
on that i just don't understand
how um they have that much money like
for two movies 450 million dollars
well the first movie was made on a 40
million dollar budget and it earned 311
million i get it it's an investment
but movies earn but it's not a beautiful
windbreaker so i can't imagine we're
gonna get much like okay play this out
with me like okay you
in a studio 40 million dollars it made
300
in theaters and dvd and on demand
netflix gives it away for free to their
customers to their subscribers but like
they think i guess the gamble here is
that even more people are going to
subscribe because they love knives out
one they've got to see two and three
they're just netflix is very much giving
me gender vibes that's all i'm trying to
say they also need to keep their
customers happy
happy netflix was giving me gen cha
vibes until
the pandemic and now it's like they're
just making money hand over fists yeah
i just don't know how like how do you
how does netflix monetize other than
charging us for our subscription i'm
sure they probably sell our data
no no but like that's period period oh
okay period you don't need multiple
revenue streams once you're selling
people's data
just ask gen cha and then you have a um
like
the subscription that they have yeah i
guess that's good yeah
i think i think they're okay okay next
story is really going to test your
memory
do you remember back in 2015 the twitter
thread that went viral
yes zola did you see the story yeah
zola the movie it's all over tick tock
oh okay zola the movie
is here i know now that the story is the
basis for zola the movie
it made its debut last year at
sundance's film festival and will hit
theaters this summer let's give people a
little background okay in 2015 a twitter
thread
went viral detailing the odessian saga
of azia minnow zola king a detroit
waitress and dancer who embarked on a
mind-boggling road trip to florida with
the schemer she met just hours before
for the schemer's name was jen shaw it's
a 148 tweet
thread that goes through all the twists
and turns of this trip that she took
and it was crazy and it went viral
then someone bought the rights to the
twitter thread and the story
said they were gonna make a movie they
made a movie here it is
it's crazy how like we got a sully movie
like before sully even finished
landing the plane on the hudson but this
movie took like five years
yeah well sully landed oh it was a
beautiful day
jackie is like a sully i'm a silly stan
you know you know what i'm saying like
they make they make movies for people
before they're even dead like
yeah and it's like why did this one take
so long no i agree budget right but i do
feel like
the longer it takes the better it's
going to be agreed sometimes i feel like
it's almost inauthentic when a movie
comes out
so quickly it's like okay 1315 to paris
yeah that movie came out literally while
the men were still on the train like it
was so
[ __ ] quick yeah no i agree it's like
we need
time time time curious time yeah like i
think american sniper did a good job
of like honoring chris kyle but like
waiting an appropriate amount of time
yeah but that was also not a story that
like
most people knew yeah that's true you
know
yeah we've just gotten into like this
weird cycle of like making movies so
fast after like
major historical events and tragedies
and it's like give people time no
time and also like let it play out you
know like things could happen years
later
yeah or just like the way that it sits
you know you got to let it ruminate
it is so important to ruminate and
while you're ruminating it's also
important to you know acknowledge the
time you're currently
oh it's important to acknowledge the
rumination stage
are you ready for our fifth and final
story it's a little charitable it's the
fifth and final
[Music]
kylie jenner donates five hundred
thousand dollars to help a teen
cancer to help teen cancer patients in
honor of friend harry hudson
oh kylie is honoring her friend harry
hudson a singer-songwriter and cancer
survivor by helping teens undergoing
cancer treatment
the star donated half a million dollars
alongside funds from nonprofit
organization teen cancer america
to build a new lounge space at
children's hospital at vanderbilt
the area will serve the unique needs of
adolescent and young adult
cancer patients according to her release
i mean i just love kylie and i really am
very
um defensive of her this does feel
like like a nice [ __ ] you to all the
people who were like you only dated five
thousand dollars to the offend me for
your
makeup artist yeah so it's like kylie's
very philanthropic and let's just stop
counting other people's money you know
um totally i'm sure someone will find a
way to make this a negative story
um but until then i think it's a
positive and considering she was getting
charity shamed last week i thought it
was important to share her charitable
acts of this week
you know the whole charity shaming space
is so confusing because like
you know okay we should we charity shame
people who don't do charity or they're
just not sharing it
so it's like but then when they do share
it it's like why are you sharing and
it's also not enough so it's like what
do we do
you know yeah it's very confusing taylor
swift
l rhodes lead back to taylor swift but
like no if you find yourself in the
business of charity shaming
maybe take a look maybe yeah maybe
recognize the space that you're in
i don't even want to say anything else
because that was so perfectly rewarded
and the show thank you so much for
listening to no we have to talk about
the thrill houses of new jersey
um the real housewives of new jersey
last night was impeccable
here's a few things that i immediately
noticed okay
need a house in the jersey shore and
honestly i just want to buy melissa from
underneath
or to contract joe gorga to build and
eat because
from the front of the house it's very
unassuming looks like you know uh
like a mid-century ranch but it
obviously has this like insane back
seven bedrooms the back yard the patio
the pool the the ocean
the bar like and it's so well done it's
amazing
it's amazing and like should they
obviously like are just like the best
versions of themselves there you know
like they are so happy it was it
i really wanted to be there but i was
also just really happy for them
me too like melissa just like making
daiquiri like the outdoor bar is so
sickening the boat the jets
the jet skis there was just so many so
many fun times to be had there
yeah i would be like really upset if
like the gorga money wasn't real because
i like how they spend it like they do it
in a nice family-friendly way
yeah no i think i well here's the thing
i wonder how long you're on tv
if you're like running you know some
sort of criminal enterprise how long are
you on tv before like the feds find out
you know i feel like they've
they're have surpassed that's true you
know like gen chad was one season i feel
like even for teresa it was like
two seasons three no like four
i don't know yeah i know you i know no i
know what you mean
you know so i think they're um safe i
mean i don't want to jinx it but i just
really um
i love them as a couple and i loved that
they finally like stood up for
themselves in the face of teresa because
they're in this space where like they
fully understand what's going on between
everything and everyone they're very
clogged like they understand the
how the world works theresa just kind of
lives in her own head so she doesn't
really understand what's going on
but for melissa and joe it's just like
constantly getting beaten down by teresa
and then also being expected to defend
her and it's just like this impossible
dynamic
to want to keep the family peace but
also like at what sacrifice like to what
end
do we just keep our sister happy while
she literally berates us yeah
and they both just [ __ ] lost their
minds and i was like happy for that i
was happy for them too i think that it
needed to happen when jojo
when joe gorga said that no man has ever
taken away more from him
than joe judicia i like felt that in my
soul and i
and he got he was so angry and and i
know it was just like all that for him
and melissa like they've been holding
this in i'm sure every night before they
go to bed they just like
talk [ __ ] and they're like but we'll
never say it for the interest of keeping
the peace of the family and i have a lot
of respect for that
but there's only so much someone can do
and it's like they'll try and keep the
peace as long as possible but when
theresa is starting to start with them
when she breaks the piece it's like oh
you want to break it
here's what we think yeah and the dinner
was so insane for a multitude of reasons
one she told me
to shut up when they were literally just
talking like how [ __ ] disrespectful
is that like jennifer aiden you're all
so concerned with how marge talks to her
husband look at how your [ __ ] best
friend talks to her sister like it's
disgusting
it's disgusting then keeps bringing it
back to joe
giudice saying that like uh melissa
delores and joe gorga need to apologize
to teresa for saying he was going to
take her money
first of all okay yes they were wrong
but they were just worried about you
like and they don't know anyone anything
no then joe gorga said that joe judich
is releasing this article about him like
saying he is dirt on joe gorga
and like threatening him and like
theresa does nothing so then teresa's
getting into her dumb
fight with jackie again and melissa and
joe were just expected to like come to
the rescue
right it's so asinine and so backwards
so backwards and i just loved when they
exploded i really did no i loved
all of the different explosions and like
there were so many other fights and like
i i felt like people even know like what
was happening when
margaret for like 0.5 seconds turned on
jackie i was glad because jackie was
being
out of control and i have to i hope like
for the sake they're fine
no no i know that they're fine like was
she so drunk because her emotions were
just like
all over the place right because she
spent most of the dinner just being like
i'm fine stop worrying about me and then
like she was literally
a puddle of tears like inconsolable and
the fact that she would like come away
from that and be so upset with joe
benigno like
stop and i'm so last morning she was i
thought margaret handled it
expertly and like she margaret was in a
tough spot
she was in a tough spot but like she
didn't back down from from
anyone and jackie needed to be told like
stop
like yeah you can't just be a big baby
you know and by the way like i
it just wasn't made clear like how joe
benigno said it because yes he did say
he heard it
but that they didn't believe it and it's
like he's he's not a paid housewife he
doesn't say things to like stir up drama
and create plot lines
he was just a guy like sharing like i
felt so
bad for him when he was sitting at that
meal like he just like had unbelievable
unbeknownst to him like made a colossal
[ __ ] up yeah and like
literally turned this whole thing upside
down and gave so much credibility to
teresa
without knowing it yeah and i felt so
bad for him i felt so bad for march and
then i did feel bad for jackie and i
feel like melissa was really the only
one
making like bringing people back down to
earth just be like
look at this girl like she's [ __ ]
broken we're talking about her marriage
like
that's off limits to us like why why
won't you stop
and i actually had a lot of respect for
melissa for going up against teresa and
just being like look at this girl like
look what you're doing it's her marriage
and i understand theresa like you don't
have a [ __ ] marriage right now maybe
you can't understand what that's like
but like at some point like just let it
go
yeah so i think things had to get really
bad before they could get
a little bit better i also the
relationship between teresa and joe
and her brother is just like the kiss on
the lips oh no i'm not worried about
that but like
it's no choice is in love with her
brother like okay
is that what you're trying to say yeah
yeah yeah yeah like if joe tells her to
do something she'll do it she loves you
no and she's just like
i think it's really hard for her and i
think and and i think like if you wanted
like i'm not you know a family therapist
like if you want to get down to the root
of like her um
disdain for melissa that's always joe
gorg as a husband she wishes
no and like yeah she wants to be like
married to her brother
no but not in a sexual way but in like
that's like
melissa takes away like like time and
energy and love from teresa
like because she's his wife and like
yeah there's like a jealousy
that's not just like girl stuff it's
like sibling
yeah no it's weird for 100 but i like
love joe and melissa's marriage so much
and i really think like
no one's in a tougher spot than joe like
having to choose
and i have a lot of respect for him that
he will always defend his wife like
against his sister
and it's not hard because his sister's
always wrong but he also like
does the best that he can and not like
blowing it up
piling on to teresa like he jumps in
when it's absolutely necessary
but like he he tries to defend her as
much as possible and that's really
all you can ask for it was just like
uncomfortable watching so many parts of
it like
of course when joe margaret and uh
jackie were fighting like i
literally wanted to die and then
watching jackie and her crazy ass hair
extensions just like
stabbed in dolores and frank's living
room like it was so [ __ ] crazy
it was when jack zone went back to
melissa's and called her husband like
again in the foyer i'm operating under
the guys that she was so drunk because
it's the only way that like i can make
sense of any of it rationalize
and like literally piling on to him and
it's like
in this instance like jackie just needs
to be stronger like for her family and
like
she'll like her husband it's obviously
really affects him and his business like
she needs to internalize she's going to
be the armor she's
not like she's just making everything
like bigger
bigger and worse and she needs to
shoulder more of it like i'm sorry
no i know she's like this is your this
is your world don't get me wrong teresa
started
this whole thing and she was
unequivocally wrong but the way jackie's
handling it
made it into a full-blown storyline and
then now she's like
i'm not giving life to this it's like
this is a teenager now no literally like
it's so silly
and and that um converse
i actually like never have had less
respect for theresa
than when she like said she didn't want
to talk to evan she's like no you could
talk to him like you know and jackie's
like no i think you should talk to him
like
really you're gonna run your mouth at
his birthday party talk [ __ ] about him
not back down
and you won't even say one [ __ ] word
to his face like and you you pretend
like you're so confident and strong
really [ __ ] like that is the most
cowardly [ __ ] i've ever seen
no it gets worse more cowardly when in
her interview she's like i'm old school
like
the husband and wife sorted out but i
guess they have a different sort of
marriage yeah like
a married yep one word you know she was
just one where they don't send each
other to jail she was off her
[ __ ] rocker last night and the fact
that she had literally the gall to say
to jackie like i don't think i want to
talk to your husband like
after all you [ __ ] done you don't
even have
the testicle to speak to this man
i just i found it appalling because you
know what say what you want about
theresa but she's a [ __ ]
beast she's strong she could go up
against anyone and that's like i don't
want to talk to your husband
yeah yeah yeah i'm like what are you
[ __ ] 11. it was crazy to me like i
was
floored and i never had less respect for
this woman in my life than i did
her standing talking jackie no i don't
want to talk to evan what
what it was crazy i have to be honest
the worst moment of the episode
for me no where i literally my hand was
like this i was like
so feeling so awkward i can't i can't it
was the worst moment
when they're on the boat and theresa is
taking pictures oh my god
yes yes jackie and evan
trying to be like sweet trying to be
like kiss and it's like
you're literally trying to bring this
cup apart like trying to
i totally forgot about that
and it's like i wanted to appreciate her
effort but she's done so much damage and
she's been so wrong i
i can't help but cringe i'm gonna like
be
sick no it was sick i'm gonna go i'm
going back in though
no that's and the fact that like jackie
and evan like obliged
and like it was community theater like
it was [ __ ]
awful no i've never felt so much from
the community theater
my god um also then things like took
another turn at lunch when the guys get
up and margin
and shout out to the guys like they
handled it like pros cause obviously you
can't shut the conversation down this is
your lives jobs they're on a show
but everything is so much more heated
and personal when the men are there
because they're literally talking about
the men but the men don't want to get
involved and like stand up for their
wives which i completely
and they don't want to turn their backs
on each other like guys knights right
they're friends like
no i have so much respect for frank
italian by the way he did not say one
word in the car about joe banigno and he
did not say one word at dinner about it
so much respect for him i have so much
respect for joe gorka being like men
up out yeah take your salads and let's
go
um but it was like
melissa i mean uh margaret and jennifer
ayden like kept saying below the belt
things to each other
but jennifer [ __ ] started it like
things were finally going well she's the
one who brought up last night
and then she just completely [ __ ]
lost the whole thing
when she said the thing about her boss
that she brought up the night before
like finally it was smoothed over like
what are you doing of course the boss
comment was like so below the belt like
took a vulnerable moment and used it and
weaponized it
but to me the initial crime is even
bringing up last night
even if you're not gonna get into a
fight with margaret why would you put
jackie and teresa like back in that
place
what are you trying to do you claim to
be teresa's friends like why are you
bringing this back up i'm so
turnt on jennifer like and even though
this is probably not even the worst
thing she's ever done
i know turn to i know it's hard because
like you want to like her like her
family stuff is like funny and
interesting and she is such a great
style and i
live for her husband but unfortunately
that's not enough to negate all of the
negativity that she brings
and after like her bringing up last
night and what she said to margaret
anything that margaret has
now said about her fair game i agree
even that word i agree and also this
concubine comment what's a concubine um
like it's really mean well it's like
she's basically said like because
jennifer was like i can't believe you
talk to your husband that way which by
the way is such a nasty thing to say
like
of course stay out of people's [ __ ]
marriages and then margaret was like
well yeah
you can't talk to your husband in any
other way because he's your [ __ ] meal
ticket you concubine
yeah a woman who lives with a man but
has lower status than his wife or wives
didn't even know there was a word for
that yeah and also that's such a word
that i think um did candace
call ashley darby a concubine i have no
idea i swear i've never
i've never heard that word i believe
that she did it's like a biblical term
and it's
like like [ __ ] it's but it's like so
specific and poignant
yeah no like and the fact that margaret
was just able to like pull that s.a.t
word out of her back pocket
we have no choice to respect no but see
like i think
of course like the the sleeping with the
boss comment was so atrocious but like
it really riled me up when she said like
i can't believe you talk to your husband
that way like first of all you don't
know how people communicate
second of all stay the [ __ ] out of
people's marriages like it was so
it's kind of bothering us learning that
it bothered me like more than all the
other stuff like because if somebody
ever said that to me i would be like
mind your own [ __ ] business
100 percentage and she was just trying
to make margaret look so bad like yeah
you talk down to your husband like it
was just like really really
disrespectful
so i'm fully team [ __ ] margaret i'm a
hundred percent team margaret
never looking back um i'm very upset
with jennifer
and you know what i actually walked out
of the episode with a little bit more
respect for dolores because for me
delores's blind spot has always been
teresa like dolores has had a really
unique way of being
the real moral compass of the show
except when it comes to matters
involving teresa
and it gets like frustrating because you
want where is that like smart wit
moral compassy vibe when it comes to the
teresa [ __ ] but she's always just kind
of been blinded by it and i feel like
last night
she um told teresa to apologize after
dinner she she
she doesn't come out as strong as she
should for theresa but at least now
she's navigating theresa in the correct
way
and she was the one who like audibly
gasped when
uh jennifer aiden said like that thing
about margaret's boss
yeah i feel like even though she's not
like you know
sticking up for she's on the wrong side
of history but she's not defending
teresa which she usually
does yeah so like she's at the wrong
shorehouse you know
i would love her no i know but like you
know what i mean like in terms of like
it's like these are the two couches
but no but like still it's like what she
said to jackie like we're cut from a
different cloth like
theresa and jennifer like they are just
more similar
you know i know but like for my personal
um enjoyment i would just like
delores on the right side of history i
know but then you'll start then you'll
get a fight between dolores and jackie
and i don't want that
not again even though that was pretty
funny okay jockey
it's high quality
every time i hear her tag like me too i
may be quite
cut from a different cloth but it's high
quality fabric
i just laugh from our assessment i know
that was like the most random [ __ ]
story like it sounds like ruxin she
literally sounds like she works in the
garment district
like she's trying to sell you know
fabric yeah it's the highest quality
fabric
um so it's it's honestly such a good
season like i
i kind of dread watching dallas i look
forward to jersey like i watched live i
was so excited to watch
no i turned on my tv at eight o'clock
found out it was on at night me too
so i rewatched the old episode what did
i oh i i put on uh discovery plus ina
garten she was making a delicious salmon
taco
it's just so good and it's like the
franchise we really needed from them
because we had a couple
rough years there yeah no it's really
good um i'm loving it
and i can't wait for next week and team
margaret for life keeping up with
kardashians is on tonight
bittersweet once again i'm headed out to
dinner so um
yum i don't know if i'm gonna watch it
like depends on how many drinks that i
have okay
see how you feel i'll give you one guess
to guess what i'm going to dinner i know
where
where your addiction yeah can i say it
zero bond yep i'll be there that's our
show
no it's not april fool's it's someone
else's
no but really that's our show thank you
so much for listening to the morning
tell us the millennial morning show we
deliver the fast-paced stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have rated cat's box all the places so
whenever we listen to podcasts find out
some morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
we hope you guys have an amazing
thursday don't forget to acknowledge the
space you're currently in
and we'll see you tomorrow for friday
friday gotta get down on friday
[Music]
goodbye